[Música]
el presidente de Francia Emanuel Mako
Avanza en su gira por el continente
africano una gira de suma importancia
para el país europeo pero que tiene un
componente político de peso en un
continente africano que se está abriendo
al mundo y es cada vez más atractivo
pero su pasado colonial con países como
por ejemplo Francia sigue siendo una
especie de herida abierta el presidente
francés comenzó la gira en Liberty la
capital de gabón allí participó en la
Cumbre internacional para la protección
de los bosques tropicales una Cumbre
llamada One Forest summit luego su gira
lo llevará hasta luanda la capital de
Angola luego a la República del Congo y
posteriormente a la República
democrática del Congo Cuál es la agenda
qué intención tiene el presidente
francés allí en África mahome visita el
continente africano con una gran
necesidad de cambio en la estrategia de
Francia hacia África también debe hacer
una renovación en cuanto a la presencia
y en la estrategia militar en ese
continente ya recientemente anunció una
contundente reducción en el número de
soldados franceses sobre todo en el área
del sael y finalmente Pues también va
allí África para mirar oportunidades que
puedan permitir hacer contrapeso a la
presencia de China y al avance de Rusia
a través de los milicianos del grupo
Wagner
dentro de los grandes anuncios que ha
hecho el presidente macó en su primera
escala en liberville está el compromiso
de entregar 50 millones de euros a un
gran esquema global para recompensar a
los países por proteger sus bosques y su
biodiversidad el tema medioambiental
también tiene gran importancia en esta
gira por África para el presidente
francés nos queda entonces para el
debate y para el análisis entender cuál
puede ser esa nueva estrategia de
Francia para el continente africano Cómo
puede hacer contrapeso a las inversiones
de China y a los milicianos rusos Qué
tipo de relación quiere Francia con
África pero también Qué tipo de relación
quiere África con Francia en ambas
direcciones la relación tiene que
cambiar a nivel político a nivel
diplomático y a nivel militar porque
ambos actores han cambiado y el pasado
colonial pues justamente es eso el
pasado y la relación debe ser renovada
en este nuevo escenario global ante una
nueva coyuntura internacional por eso
hoy el debate de France 24 Francia se
termina entonces la injerencia francesa
en el continente africano vamos a
conversar sobre este tema con Biblia
ella es presidenta de puerta de África
ella se encuentra en la ciudad de
Barcelona en España y desde la ciudad de
Las Palmas en gran canaria también en
España está con nosotros dagú comment él
es historiador especializado en
relaciones internacionales y conocedor
de temas africanos te recuerdo que
ustedes nuestros televidentes también
hacen parte de este debate pueden dejar
todos sus comentarios y sus preguntas a
través de las redes sociales estamos en
Twitter en Facebook en instagram ustedes
ya lo conocen ya lo conocen nuestra
cuenta es arroba
franz24_es la etiqueta para que dejen
los comentarios numeral el debate f24
todo pegado todo junto y a mí me
encuentran en Twitter como arroba
santilogo no olviden también que todos
los contenidos de nuestro programa están
disponibles en Apple podcast en Spotify
en deezer y en TuneIn
comienzo dándole la bienvenida a Vivian
en la ciudad de Barcelona en Cataluña en
España Vivian Gracias por estar con
nosotros en el debate y la pregunta que
he elegido para este Punto de partida es
que esta visita tiene lugar en una
coyuntura muy particular para el
continente africano y particular también
para las ex colonias francesas
qué análisis puede hacer usted de la
coyuntura y del momento que está
viviendo África en la actualidad y que
reciba al presidente francés dado el
escenario que se está presentando
bueno primero Buenos días buenas tardes
para ustedes Muchas gracias por
invitarme creo que es muy interesante
entender que en este momento estamos en
Bueno estamos viendo un cambio de
paradigma en las relaciones entre la
Unión Europea y
África en el que África está utilizando
una serie de estrategias para determinar
Su futuro de una manera Más directa para
construir
unas nuevas relaciones con la unión
acercándose a Rusia en algunos casos
ya hace muchos años de la presencia
China y también diversificando todas sus
opciones con con los países emergentes y
también dentro de la propiedad eficaz
están desarrollando proyectos como puede
ser el área de libre comercio para
reforzar sus capacidades Entonces si
esta gira se está dando en un momento de
cambio que es muy muy importante tener y
explorar
vamos a hacerle la misma pregunta a
nuestro siguiente invitado en la ciudad
de Las Palmas en gran canaria Bienvenido
al programa Gracias por estar con
nosotros como siempre Un gusto conversar
con ustedes y la misma la misma pregunta
cómo es el escenario que se está
viviendo en África la coyuntura actual y
Porque es importante Esta visita del
jefe de estado francés
Bueno quería darle las gracias por
invitarme otra vez y lo que se presenta
es una encrucijada puedo decir porque
ahora mismo
Francia Está frente a una competencia
muy dura O parte tanto de China de Rusia
pero también de otros países emergentes
como India y Turquía Entonces es un
momento histórico digamos porque Francia
no suele tener tal competición ante en
lo que trata de sus relaciones con los
países africanos Así que pienso que esta
donde Francia tiene que repensar su
política africana para intentar ser más
competitiva frente a estos nuevos
actores que han entrando en el entrado
en el mercado africano Dago continuó con
usted para hacer la ronda la inversa
mencionaba yo en la introducción del
programa esta necesidad de ambas partes
tanto de África como de Francia de
renovar esta relación escalarlas a otro
nivel para tener un mejor entendimiento
entre las entre las partes cómo puede
ser esa relación que se establezca entre
África No necesariamente con las ex
colonias francesas porque vemos que el
presidente Mako va a visitar también
Angola que es una ex Colonia portuguesa
y la República democrática del Congo que
era una ex Colonia belga entonces aquí
muestra un poco de apertura más amplia
digámoslo así a llegar a otros mercados
a interactuar con otro tipo de países
como debe ser esa relación entre las
partes
bueno en primer lugar
la relación tiene que tener una base de
respeto mutuo porque es una de las
principales acusaciones que que lleva
Francia de ser un poco invasiva no en
las asuntos interiores de los estados
africanos y pienso que la principal cosa
que puede hacer Francia ahora mismo Para
sanar esta relación este pasivo no
turbio que existe entre Entre ella y los
países africanos principalmente intentar
cambiar este paradigma cambiar esta
forma de condescendencia que ha sido muy
recurrente en la relación entre el país
y europeo y los países africanos no solo
los países del Antiguo imperio colonial
pero también sobre todo también países
como Guinea ecuatorial Guinea Perdón
visado que han entrado también con el
funcifa en la órbita de Francia y la
república democrática de Congo que
también en algunos aspectos ha sido muy
vinculado vinculada con Francia
Vivian qué piensa usted al respecto
Cuáles deben de ser entonces Esas bases
de entendimiento entre Francia y estos
países africanos
estoy muy de acuerdo con Davo primero
creo que también es muy importante ver
que macrón no solamente es el presidente
de la república francesa sino que
también forma parte de la Unión Europea
no Entonces en este marco de este nuevo
en este cambio internacional la Unión
Europea como actor tiene mucho tiene
mucha importancia entonces pero también
esto es interesante ver y tenerlo
presente cuando vemos Que macron
a través de todo el continente estoy muy
de acuerdo con con lo que ha planteado
África quiere una relación es como se
dice en francés cañón no win-win
unas relaciones en las que se pueda
construir desde el respeto mutuo Pero al
final los países africanos están
tratando de beneficiarse al máximo no
utilizan digamos las mismas estrategias
y las mismas premisas que cualquier otro
estado en el mundo África quiere ser
capaz de desarrollarse por sí misma ser
capaz de liderar su propio futuro además
de ser un actor relevante en el
escenario internacional y va a utilizar
la relación con los diferentes actores
con diferentes países para ello Entonces
si Francia y la Unión Europea son
capaces de ofrecer
Los acuerdos las
colaboraciones necesarias para que esto
ocurra pues estos países no van a tener
quizás tanta necesidad de redirigirse de
otros estados pero también tienen que
reducirse las condicionalidades no
entonces creo que estos son dos
elementos importantes y luego quizás me
remitiría un poco más a la sociedad
civil pero también lo hablan
también se habla desde desde los
gobiernos no y es que hay una necesidad
de reparación
la sociedad civil plantea mucho el
término no de las reparaciones el
reconocimiento macron está haciendo esto
ha hecho un está haciendo la restitución
de bienes entonces creo que aquí pues
entraría no quizás un poco la cuestión
del cambio climático que diferentes
movimientos sociales están planteando un
fondo
para para paliar los efectos del cambio
climático para la para construir
resiliencia y otros aspectos
como un fondo de reparaciones por las
consecuencias de las relaciones las
partes más difíciles de la relación Sí
continuó con usted allí en la ciudad de
Barcelona parte de esta renovación y
estas nuevas bases de una relación entre
el continente africano y Francia y bueno
y Por ende con la Unión Europea también
pasa por empezar a cerrar esas heridas
del pasado que mencionaba Yo también en
la introducción de el programa que
siempre ante las dificultades los países
africanos
sacan estos reclamos históricos válidos
o no desde el punto de vista que uno lo
quiera ver eso daría para otro debate
pero siempre salen a estos reclamos
hacia las potencias europeas por el
pasado colonial cito el presidente
macron cuando él dice que
hay una percepción por lo menos allá en
el gobierno francés que hay una idea
demasiado instalada en África de que
Francia es la responsable de todo y
cuando hay una decepción la gente
simplemente va y dice que es culpa de
Francia a estas alturas cuando ya los
países tienen gobiernos instalados son
independientes y digamos que son
Víctimas de su propio destino de elegir
a los gobernantes que han tenido de
pasar por los momentos históricos que
han tenido esta herida Cómo se puede
cerrar Y si esta herida que está
permanentemente abierta puede seguir
siendo una piedra en el zapato para que
esta relación evolucione
muy buena pregunta sí que es cierto que
ahí está responsabilidad doble en tanto
en Francia también hay una
autorresponsabilidad de tener que
participar y contribuir de las
cuestiones africanas por esa
responsabilidad histórica colonial y
también es cierto que se vive con el
auge del movimiento bueno vemos el auge
del movimiento
africana y en otros países
si esta tendencia a culpabilizar a
Francia ahora mismo Manuel macron ya ha
empezado una una estrategia para tratar
de paliar estos estos síntomas
a nivel comunicativo lo que ha hecho es
empezar un ejercicio de reconocimiento
de elementos que no se habían reconocido
antes no y al final en una en un proceso
de construcción de paz lo que lo que se
tiene que hacer por una parte no es
digamos este acto de reconocimiento de
negociación y encontrar el camino
conjunto
es una es una tarea complicada y van a
tener que o sea van a tener que trabajar
también para reconocer las cuestiones
poscoloniales que no han no han avanzado
de la manera que tendrían que haber
avanzado esto es una cuestión que
también la ha reconocido Manuel macron
que han habido comportamientos
inadecuados en la etapa poscolonial y
claramente también tiene que haber un
eje de responsabilidad de los gobiernos
no
Sí claro aquí si la relación no está
fluyendo es porque hay ambas partes que
están teniendo puntos en donde no están
coincidiendo y básicamente eso es lo que
se está tratando de Buscar no solamente
con Francia sino también con otros
países europeos Dago su opinión sobre
este punto importante de ver
esta fácil acusación digámoslo así de
países africanos de hacia Francia de
culpable de todo no solamente pasa con
Francia también pasa con el Reino Unido
en cierta forma Portugal y España Pero
estas acusaciones que van y vienen es
momento de cerrar esta estas
discrepancias y ponerse de acuerdo para
sacar una relación fructífera para ambas
partes
exactamente es momento de cerrarla pero
el Cómo es la clave
una de los uno de los elementos es que
no hay un sentimiento antifrancés Hay un
sentimiento
antifransafique es diferente
es un es un concepto que abarca tanto a
Francia como a una cierta élite africana
Así que no existe
un sentimiento contra Francia sino
también contra una cierta élite que se
aprovecha de su propia población el
segundo lugar yo pienso que a pesar de
los esfuerzos del presidente macron
pienso es que pienso que peca en no
escuchar a los a los africanos porque el
bloque falta No si no se le escucha lo
bastante piden una serie de cosas y es
cierto que es difícil llegar hasta este
punto por ejemplo el Franco cefa el
cierre de militares y hay una serie de
cosas que constituían que sigan
constituyendo una herida que que impide
no la reconciliación entre Francia y
sobre todo las sociedades civiles
africanas si se habla mucho de que es
historia pero en 2014 son fuerzas
especiales francesa que evacuaron o que
ayudaron al presidente a escapar de la
injusticia y a exiliarse a Costa de
Marfil Así que no no se trata de cosas
que que son de la década de los 60 del
siglo 20 sino son una serie de
acontecimientos que han que se han
repetido a través de la historia
africana sobre todo cuando toca los
países del Antiguo
imperio colonial francés y esos son los
elementos que fundamentan este
sentimiento y que usan competidores de
Francia para
posicionarse en el mercado claro y son y
son reclamos que tienen cierto
fundamento todo hay que decirlo usted
cita y se adelanta un poco en un tema
que yo quería tratar Dago lo va a poner
ya sobre la mesa y es este concepto de
Francia Freak el presidente dijo en
París que esto Simplemente ya terminó
tratando de cerrar ese capítulo y
empezar a abrir las nuevas páginas del
nuevo capítulo en esa relación con
África para usted para su análisis este
concepto de Francia Freak y esta forma
de relacionarse ya terminó
Bueno desde mi punto de vista no
porque en primer lugar hay que saber lo
que es
la función está basada en tres Pilares
principales el primero el primero es la
moneda del franco cifa el segundo en la
presencia militar y el tercer Pilar es
la complicidad y los líderes africanos
a este a este sistema
estos tres elementos siguen presente
actualmente se ha visto esta estos
elementos en la crisis de los tercer
mandatos en África occidental por
ejemplo y uno de las de los elementos
por ejemplo que la gente está usando
ahora mismo contra la visita del
presidente macront es que el presidente
de gabón
Bongo está tiene la población tiene una
una sospecha de Que quiere pretender un
tercer mandato y ya ha visto que en la
historia francesa en la historia de
Francia con África hubo estos cómo se
llama
estas colaboraciones para ayudar a
perpetuar en el poder a gobernantes que
son a favor de Francia exactamente de
hecho hay muchas voces en gabón que
están interpretando la visita del
presidente macron allí como una un apoyo
tácito a su nueva candidatura puesto lo
ocurrido en la última de 2016 sí Y es
una duda válida que pueden tener los
jaboneses frente a la situación política
del país vivían su opinión sobre este
término de la de la Francia Freak como
lo explicaba Dago desde su perspectiva
esto se mantiene Esto no se ha terminado
como lo decía el presidente francés que
ya lo daba por cerrado un capítulo menos
que discutir con los africanos
si bien es cierto que
en los diferentes gobiernos en tanto
oland como Macro han ido haciendo
avances para tratar de cerrar el
capítulo de la danza lo que lo que
tienen yo creo la bueno la fenta se
define como una un un una red de actores
que colaboran entre ellos no es decir es
toda toda una toda una estructura de
apelaciones de poder
de empresas de líderes que colaboran Y
eso es muy difícil de de romper no la
cuestión es como esto puede
transformarse no como hasta al día de
hoy quizás o ha tenido todo un impacto
negativo desde lo percibido por la
población hoy ha tenido un impacto
negativo y cómo Esto puede cambiar a un
modelo de relaciones muchísimo más
abierto más liberal en el que no no haya
tanta complicidad en ciertos ambientes
que permita
que también hayan voces disonantes
en los gobiernos con con Europa y eso es
lo que tiene que ocurrir no Y ser
capaces de utilizar otras estrategias
para trabajar en conjunto para avanzar
entendiendo el uso de la historia
entonces
creo que no creo que que la franja pri
como tal no ha terminado pero tampoco la
la veo
o sea quiero decir
No termina pero tiene algunas algunos
algunas bases que todavía se mantienen
ahí que han empezado a cerrar Tal vez un
poco
la historia que ha tenido en el en el
continente africano es tal vez tratando
de entender lo que lo que nos dabas
conocer Vivian Sí bueno continuo con
usted Vivian porque hay algo que me
quedó dando vueltas en la cabeza de algo
que usted mencionó y es la presencia de
Francia en el Continente pero usted
mencionaba también la Unión Europea
no sé si usted coincide que lo que uno
puede ver de esta giras que Francia
también Está tratando de tomar un poco
de ventaja de la posición que tiene como
expotencia colonial allí en África Para
aprovechar que África justamente se está
abriendo al mundo y está ávida de
inversiones y de conectarse con el resto
de países del mundo Más allá de Europa
Francia claramente está tomando una
ventaja frente a otros países no
viéndolo como un territorio colonial
porque Dago mencionaba a India y a
Turquía por ejemplo que no tienen ningún
tipo de historia relaciona con con la
colonización africana pero están
sólidamente presentes allí sobre todo
Turquía en el área comercial está muy
presente allí y en el área de
inversiones En infraestructura
compitiéndole a China Francia toma
ventaja frente a otros países europeos
Francia tiene ventaja frente a otros
países europeos por por la posición que
tiene Francia al final
sí que trabaja con los diferentes países
y hay una cuestión no los acuerdos post
aún no se han firmado es decir esa
interlocución entre la Unión Europea y
la unión africana los Estados Unidos de
la unión africana no se está dando en un
marco de relaciones nuevo entonces para
aparte de que hay cuestiones internas
europeas que están frenando El Avance de
ya la ratificación de los acuerdos Pues
sí Francia quiere mantener su estatus de
poder porque al final es lo que le da
también cierto mucha más relevancia a
nivel internacional lo que justifica su
presencia y su y su influencia en
organizaciones como el consejo de
seguridad de Naciones Unidas
[Música]
también se está valiendo del apoyo de
otros países para hacer ese trabajo y
por ejemplo en el zagel hemos visto la
Europea izaización de la misa entonces
yo veo más a Francia como como rol de de
interlocutor entendiendo que Europa
también quiere constituirse como un ente
conjunto para hacer frente a los cambios
globales que estamos viviendo
manteniendo este papel que tiene claro
Cuál es su opinión Francia parte con
ventaja Francia toma ventaja a raíz de
Esta visita del presidente Mako frente a
otros países europeos que piensa usted
Obviamente que Francia tiene una una
ventaja una ventaja Clara Porque primero
por el pasado a pesar de tener todas
estas trabas todo ese esos problemas
todo ese pasivo no turbio muchos de los
países africanos han crecido
aprendiendo y pensando en francés de
hecho así que es más fácil para ellos
identificarse a un presidente francés No
sé ustedes si lo ven en los países
africanos las cadenas francesas como
franciscar cuatro o otros medios
franceses están tienen mucha audiencia
porque hay este este sentimiento que a
veces otros países no han no han sabido
mantener con con sus antiguas colonias
Pienso que una de las razones que hace
también difícil
el la reconciliación no entre la
sociedad civil y Francia porque es una
historia digamos muy apasionada no llena
de altibajos que hace que
una proximidad muy fuerte que hace que
se ve que se vean más los defectos al
contrario de otros que se han alejado Y
así pues la imágenes se han se han
vuelto más bella no con el paso del
tiempo y eso eso es mi mi posición y
además en el discurso previo a la gira
se veía al presidente macron hablando de
Europa de Europa mientras desarrollaba
la la estrategia francesa Y es que
también eso es una de las ventajas que
tiene porque a muchos cuando
piensan Europa Pues en Francia que viene
primero los demás después sí
es prácticamente la puerta para muchos
temas africanos o vistos desde África La
puerta es Francia para llegar a Europa
punto importante de esta gira es
justamente el contrapeso que quiere
hacer Francia y Por ende la Unión
Europea a la presencia de china que está
muy metida en este continente con
inmensas obras de infraestructura e
inversiones en diferentes países del
continente pero también la presencia de
los
de este ejército privado creado en Rusia
llamado Wagner que tiene una amplia
presencia en países como Libia en donde
hay una gran cantidad de recursos
petroleros y también en la República
centroafricana un país que no está
incluido en esta gira pero que también
era Colonia francesa y es muy importante
para París y para Europa entender creo
que está pasando allí lo que uno ve
desde desde América Latina Vivian Idaho
es que se le critica la presencia
francesa en la República centroafricana
porque estaba allí para explotar y sacar
los recursos pero este grupo Wagner
aparte de proteger a un presidente
también está haciendo uso de los
recursos como los diamantes que salen de
la República centroafricana cambiaron
los franceses por los rusos Quién
entiende esto Vivian
y es una cuestión
no se puede negar el impacto de que
Wagner puede tener en los países en los
que está participando el impacto
negativo con la contracción de los
conflictos y también la extracción de
recursos
la cuestión de base aquí es que estos
países que sí que en general siguen
patrones similares en en cuestiones de
gobernanza hacen una ruptura política no
es decir en las condiciones en las que
se encuentran en las que se encontraban
trabajando con Francia pues no han visto
una una mejora de sus condiciones
nacionales sin negar el el la
responsabilidad de estos propios
gobiernos no Entonces en este marco se
aparece un nuevo actor que hace una
oferta muy similar a la oferta francesa
porque no es tan especialmente pero no
tiene cierto requerimientos de
en ciertos aspectos la gestión
gubernamental y otras cuestiones
Entonces yo creo que este es el motivo
de base por el cual estos países
más con derivas autoritarias pues han
tomado la decisión de irse con Rusia
vivían y tal vez estos gobiernos no
están midiendo el riesgo que están
tomando al mediano plazo en términos de
seguridad y lo que le puede cobrar esto
en un futuro a cada país tener a este
grupo de mercenarios
lo pregunto por la coyuntura que está
viviendo Rusia en este momento a nivel
internacional y porque no sabemos Cuál
va a ser el desenlace de la guerra en
Ucrania que también tiene algo de
conexión con esto porque Los mercenarios
también están involucrados en este
conflicto Entonces no sabemos qué
escenario se pueden abrir en África con
estos grupos de este ejército privado
Allí están poniendo mucho en riesgo no
lo ve usted así
a ver yo pienso que los gobiernos que
han tomado estas decisiones deben haber
calculado estos riesgos
pero han tomado esa decisión yo coincido
con que en el medio de una crisis
Internacional del Calibre ucraniano
de la crisis de Ucrania pues van a ver
pueden haber vencedores y perdedores
pero en este caso los gobiernos
emergentes han tomado la decisión de
avanzar con con Wagner también por las
condiciones internas de sus gobiernos yo
creo que tienen la capacidad de de
vislumbrar el futuro que puede venir y
ha sido una una decisión que para ellos
es una recepción racional Cuál es su
opinión sobre este tema
Bueno yo no pienso que los gobiernos lo
hayan pensado así como
concienzudamente
creo que respondió una situación de
emergencia sabes como como historiador
me gusta que vayamos a la raíz del
asunto como Wagner llegas al caso en
turafricana Pues precisamente porque el
presidente francés decidió acabar con la
operación sangaris y el presidente
toadera que acabas de hacer elegido
Necesitaba alguien para protegerle y se
se agarró a la primera fuerza que le
prometió
mantener su régimen a salvo es lo que ha
pasado en en República africana Así que
veo que lo que estoy pensando es que más
bien hay una demanda Y cuando esta
demanda no no encuentra un como un una
solución no
el primero que se presenta Pues ahora
mismo se ve que en República
centroafricana Estados Unidos intenta
hacer una propuesta para librarse de
Wagner pero esta propuesta Viene un poco
tarde no es que en Pradera desde 2016
necesitaba un protector y ahora que
están arraigado ahora que Estados Unidos
está pidiendo que se vayan los debagner
es una de las cosas es uno de esos
pequeños errores que hacen los países
occidentales a la hora de cooperar con
los africanos y que se aprovechan los
competidores ya llama a los Rusia china
Turquía o otros y así lo percibo Yo sí
es un punto importante le preocupa mucho
a África perdón a Europa la seguridad
africana porque Por ende un África
insegura que piensa usted dagó una
África insegura es Por ende una Europa
vulnerable como lo ve usted
pues es cierto que
una Europa fuerte necesita también una
África fuerte porque hay un vínculo
tanto económicos porque estaba hablando
de economía desde el principio pero
también no no hay que perder de vista el
fenómeno migratorio y esto parte también
de la inestabilidad que conoce el
continente y este inestabilidad mientras
el continente no alcanza un cierto nivel
de estabilidad tanto político pero en
política como económica pues va a tener
una Europa que siempre estarán gastando
o invirtiendo en una política de de
seguridad para para frenar la migración
irregular o que para adentrarse operar
con operaciones militares dentro dentro
del continente Así que es un es para el
beneficio mutuo tener un continente
africano más estable y más próspero
digamos lo de esta forma Claro porque
como usted dice no es solamente la
seguridad de de estos no sé temas como
los grupos yihadistas el narcotráfico
que viene de la droga de Suramérica que
entra a través de África occidental para
llegar a Europa los grupos de trata de
personas y de que tratan de llegar a
Europa y a otros países de medio oriente
el tema de seguridad es bastante
complejo y es una preocupación para
Europa vamos llegando ya al bloque final
de el programa quiero que hagamos las
conclusiones de lo que deja entonces
esta gira que todavía está en curso allí
en el continente africano faltan varios
países a mí me llama mucho la atención
que el presidente vaya a visitar Angola
que tiene por ser una colonia portuguesa
pues tiene una relación muy grande con
con el gobierno de Lisboa pero se abre a
Francia en búsqueda de de muchos
inversionistas ávida de inversión para
mejorar su economía y Buscó al
presidente macron Para eso su conclusión
Vivian de lo que deja esta esta gira
africana puede ser el inicio de un
segundo capítulo de la historia de estos
de estas dos áreas
yo no creo que sea el inicio de un
segundo capítulo Yo creo que es la
continuación de la competición
macron está visitando África también
África se irá a Rusia en poco tiempo y
van a seguir dando van a seguir
negociando con diferentes actores
entonces lo que se va a ver va a ser que
en ciertas áreas algunos países van a
acercarse más a los países emergentes en
otras áreas van a reforzar la relación
con Europa y yo creo que lo fundamental
aquí va a ser ver cuáles son los
intereses particulares de cada estado y
de la unión africana de los países de la
unión africana en su conjunto por las
estrategias que tienen sí
Lamentablemente decir que esto es como
un nuevo escenario de un nuevo reparto
africano los que se van a ir con los
franceses los que se quedan con los
rusos Quienes se van con India Quienes
se mantienen con los chinos y vuelve a
un escenario pero en una coyuntura
diferente Dago su opinión
Bueno creo que sí es un tipo de un nuevo
reparto sin embargo esta vez los
africanos mismos van a decidir con quién
van a ir al contrario lo que ha pasado
en el pasado o decidieron sus destinos
Sin ellos Entonces pienso que sí hay un
nuevo capítulo pero no a un nuevo
capítulo que abrió Francia sino que
abrieron los africanos mismos al
intentar diversificar sus sus socios
comerciales y en términos de seguridad
Pues esta gira Todavía está en marcha
veremos Cuáles son las grandes
conclusiones que deja Esta visita por el
continente africano de el presidente de
francés Emmanuel Mako como siempre las
visitas de los jefes de estado europeos
en este continente pues generan
controversia de debate y por eso lo
estamos analizando aquí en el debate de
France 24 a Vivian y a dagol les
agradezco mucho por haber estado con
nosotros haber hecho el análisis sobre
este tema política africana Nunca es
fácil para verlo desde América Latina
gracias por por explicarlo en palabras
simples
a ustedes les agradezco también por la
sintonía gracias por haber estado con
nosotros y en nombre de todo el equipo
técnico del debate Les agradecemos su
sintonía al programa estuvo producido
por el Laura garzón y la producción de
invitados estuvo a cargo de Tania
Herrera ya saben que pueden seguir
dejando sus comentarios y más
información la encuentran en France
24.com
[Música]